[Music]
oh
yes
credits are rolling right now four hours
later that was
a surprisingly quick four hours
absolutely
wow enjoyable four hours
[Music]
the action was incredible and like the
just the
build up by the time you get to the
finale moments you're like they're a
real
team you really feel like they care
about each other earns
everybody there's still like plenty of
surprises
uh you know we all know jared little's
gonna be in this movie uh his
his time in the movie you're like oh
yeah i was better than any time
suicide is fun but we're literally just
doing this as the credits are rolling
right now
i loved it i i really i mean it i i
loved it like that time just flew by
literally we're being we're being
recorded on the
camera right now i cried like twice yeah
yeah i cried i cried like twice i
cheered a few times like this
this movie is is well i mean it's four
hours long it's well paid but you know
what it is every scene felt
necessary every scene felt purposeful
yeah you know it's like a different tone
than bvs or man of steel
and building on those tones still the
same way helms deep is kind of the
the most dark nasty chapter of a trilogy
like bvs kind of is for this and then
yeah just
that is definitely here but mixed with
oh
so much triumph this movie is well worth
it if you've been
thinking that this isn't going to be a
different movie
you were so wrong
more than just like there's scenes in
context that is completely absent from
the
um other version even the scenes when
uh you're like okay yeah that's in the
other cut
they're either expanded upon or you know
the color is different
but they're either way that's always
recontextualized
in a way that makes it better
like every scene that you might have
seen kind of in the other one
like i said it's either longer plays out
differently
and just with all the additional context
the scenes just
work that much better like there's i
can't really think of something i didn't
like in this
like this is all pretty damn great
really i mean
if you zoom in you're like well there
are a few expositional info dumps but
like of course but we need that
for this even
uh yeah i think there's plenty of
surprises in here and there's plenty of
um great scenes and like everyone is
just so much
cooler and so much more badass to quote
aquaman
everyone is so much more fleshed out i'm
telling you by the time you get to the
finale you're like
i really feel like these guys care about
each other yeah there's some great
quieter scenes between the two of them
between like two characters just
interacting with each other that takes
time for those to to actually build not
only the league
in its physical you know fighting the
the circumstances form but also
as people together you know facing
insurmountable odds
every journey feels like incredibly
personal
yeah everyone's journey feels personal
and yeah the visual effects are just
dynamite dude
the dynamite like the music the sound
designs
and i keep forgetting like zack snyder i
think he shot this himself and like it
it looks amazing from uh
i think though the reshoot scenes he
definitely shot himself too yeah
the lighting the cam like the lens like
everything is is exquisite
i mean i just love the tone and you feel
like a real
harrowing build throughout that by the
time you're getting to the finale
moments you do feel like
the league is uniting you know and that
you feel like there's real peril and
like steppenwolf is so much better in
this
like he's a real character with a real
purpose and
like this desperation and the you know
it's like it's definitely more violent
there's a couple of moments i was like
whoa that's that's right it's raider r
yeah yeah there's a couple of moments
like that and a couple of f-bombs here
are there but the
um the violence like it packs a punch
like the the action is just so much more
fleshed out
yeah these are all quick thoughts um you
know i know we're not sounding the most
concise right now but
i do gotta say like this one
just yeah justice league too yeah get on
it
start demanding that jake justice league
restore restore the universe
versus the snyder verse i get the air
cut too if
it is full circle it gave me everything
like a lot of what we talked about in
the trailers gave me
everything i wanted there was a lot that
wasn't ruined or spoiled for me
and um when it makes the vision of
least zack snyder's three films very
clear from man of steel to now yeah
a hundred percent clear as a complete
trilogy
yeah it's cyborg really is the heart of
the story i cared a [ __ ] ton about like
i cared about everyone
everyone everyone i thought was
necessary and great yes it's more
serious
every character is more serious than the
other version
but they never lose their personality
like there's still
so much personality in this film and
every
triumphant moment feels earned the peril
feels
real this is this is like i i am so
this is worth it guys this is worth it
yeah
yeah it is a transformed experience from
what you've seen before
oh god it's so good yeah so good
holy crap i i think what we'll have to
do is like do a spoiler talk i think
that's what we'll have to do is like do
a spoiler discussion
maybe do a live stream one because this
is gonna take a while to edit
you know this is going to take a while
to edit so yeah maybe thursday or friday
we'll do like a live stream spoiler talk
you guys just throw in questions and
stuff and we just have some fun
because yeah this is going to take us
what format to put this all in and then
start editing it all
so hopefully yeah the full length will
be up on on patreon but
uh then maybe we'll put that up early
but the reaction highlights hopefully we
can get that visible here on youtube
this is revealed in the vanity fair
article uh when it says for autumn
at the end of the movie i mean that's
just that's what this is all about
i just hope zack zader knows like people
will be satisfied with this this is
amazing
and uh yeah absolutely for autumn this
is
this is [ __ ] beautiful i'm not
bullshitting you i didn't expect to cry
crying actually
i was i was really my heart was warmed
up so much
i was excited i was nervous i was uh
my heart in dust it's a little bit tough
there's a lot there's a lot of emotions
a lot of emotions man this is a really
this is a damn good experience sit down
with it
if you can commit to four to five hours
if you need to take break i totally get
it but
do it do it seriously what you were
hoping watch this one
and and i feel like i do i do think even
if you're you weren't maybe weren't the
biggest fan
of man of steel or bvs this is still
it still feels very different than those
ones i would i would definitely give it
a watch
i would definitely give it a watch like
this is this is a really awesome movie
um i was what's playing right now
oh damn oh wait we gotta turn this off
this we gotta listen to this thank you
guys thank you watch this